citizens of the reject Nation welcome and this
is going to be a very different video from me
before we get into it please do the YouTube
things like subscribe hit that notification
Bell comments because after I say the things
I'm about to say a lot of you might leave so
I'm saying it up front because this is going to
be a different kind of video that might anger a
decent amount of you but I've been angry for a
while now and I've had this conversation with
a lot of people and I thought it was time to
have this conversation here with you this is
the reason for koi's Comic Corner these are the
kind of things I want to start turning this into
and if this does well and if you like it please do
let me know leave a comment below about this type
of video basically I'm going to be talking about
my experience with a certain thing in comic books
that I think is messy and I hope that you are
with me and if you disagree at least be patient
and at least uh try to see where I'm coming
from because it is spicy I think not rebooting
the Snyder cut is the best thing for Batman and
Superman and on top of that I think we need the
Batman and Superman that we're about to get with
the DCU more than ever because of the Snyder cut
so right at the top I just need to address
the fact that there are people that think that
Superman should be murderous should wear a black
suit all the time should be the version of him
that snaps someone's neck and I understand
that between the Zack Snyder films and the
animated series and all of these things that is
a version of the character that they see as the
true version of the character I should also say
at the top that I think Zack Snyder and Deborah
Snyder are absolutely fantastic I think they are
genius creators I think she is one a Powerhouse
producer he is a Powerhouse producer director
Creator but I think what that little Universe
has spawned is a very very tricky situation while
liking the Snyders I've had conversations with the
Snyder so I know that I like them as people and
know that I enjoy these Snyder films but I will
completely own that I think of the Snyder films as
an else world I think of the Snyder Superman and
Batman as something that would be a take on the
character that wouldn't be Canon and that's gonna
be what this is that's this conversation Superman
was invented in 1938. Superman was invented by two
scrawny Jewish guys as a means to cope with the
depression that was going on leading up to World
War II being picked on and they made a symbol of
Hope and this symbol of Hope has become a symbol
of aggression and violence that a lot of people
are arguing like yeah but it's growth it's an
ark it's a trajectory you need the trajectory to
start with the essence of the character and then
have something change the dark character takes
work because they're a dichotomy the reason that
Craven's the last Hunt is interesting is because
it's like whoa what's happening to Spider-Man
Back in Black likewise the reason that Batman is
interesting is because he is very different to
Superman and their dynamic duo hood is because
they are different if Superman is as dark as
Batman then he's no longer about altruism and hope
he becomes a cautionary tale now I mentioned 1938
I mentioned these two skinny Jewish guys making
a figure for hope I also need to acknowledge the
fact that them being Jewish is so essential to
the character in that we've now made him a Christ
figure which is the most white American thing
to do when he literally was delivered a la Bread
Basket like Moses a very Jewish iconography
so this is a story of an alien an immigrant
a person that is trying to be the best possible
version that has become this this angry God he's
become this Old Testament God for multiple movies
so much so they put him in a black suit when we
hadn't really had the positive one yet if in the
first film he snapped someone's neck by the time
he gets to the black suit well I don't see much
of a difference if you get to this character that
is supposed to represent what we can become and
what we can become is someone that doesn't think
to save civilians as he's flying through buildings
who has a higher body count than most the villains
we've seen in comic book movies then that's not
something to Aspire towards the reason Superman
is in a bright suit with external underwear is to
make us think that man that's comfort in believing
in yourself man that is the ultimate in this golly
GE attitude of just hope and belief and dreams and
I think a huge problem with the the world that is
has been spawned by this Superman and again I have
a lot of love for Zack Snyder and I have a lot of
love for Deborah Snyder and I have a lot of love
for DC fans that haven't become this aggressive
angry cult that is getting DC in issues the world
of DC the the shape of Warner Brothers is lesser
for this very very vocal vitrollic group of people
that threaten that troll that become issues to the
properties at large that cause box office issues
but because now the suits that aren't comic fans
don't know how to steer this ship they tried to
make the Snyder cut it had to be released in the
way it was because of a lot of other situations
but if you even if you look at the movies that
were working if you look at bvs it had a 69 drop
off from week one to two yes it made 830 million
dollars worldwide but the drop off when people
heard about it was substantial because a lot of
people like me didn't see that as their Superman
and now don't have a place to talk about it every
time I mentioned Superman all I get is this well
that's a really interesting novel idea of the
character oh well Superman's not this anymore
or my favorite oh the world we live in is dark and
gritty and Superman should reflect that Superman
as I said at the top reflects what we're trying to
get out of if Superman reflects the world it's not
Superman Superman is our aspirational character
while Batman is our cautionary tale they invented
Superman as something to achieve to escape how bad
the world was if we make him dark and gritty we're
looking in at ourselves and going like I guess
that's fine I guess that's enough we'll just stay
here we need a Superman like the one they look
to be adapting All-Star Superman has the opening
issue literally have Lex Luthor trick Superman
into killing himself via the sun doesn't need
Krypton doesn't need doomsday doesn't need things
it shows the genius of Lex Luthor which is a human
that can take out a God it shows Superman doing
anything he can to save everyone even realizing
man the sun itself is the thing that that gives
me my power how ironic it might be thing it kills
me but accepting that he helped save people so
that was worth it we need the literal son he's
a Sun God we look to the Sun for hope I am so
sick of people not realizing that this character
represents the thing on his chest I am so sick
of very very angry people going I want my hero
to be angry like me I think there's a point in
every young man's life and I'd say a lot of young
women's life but I've never been a young woman
where they go like I don't get Superman because
he's too golly gee he's too powerful he's too
strong he has no weaknesses I get all that I used
to feel that way but I think there's a point when
you realize oh he's a figurehead to represent what
we can be he shouldn't be realistic he shouldn't
be something that we can actually aspire to if
you achieve your goals they're no longer goals if
you've ever wanted something really bad when you
got it it kind of felt like well that wasn't
what I wanted it's because dopamine is from
wanting a thing not actually always achieving
the thing Superman should be that he should
be the Line in the Sand that moves you should
always try to be better even Superman always
tries to be better so I am so sick of people
wanting this gritty Superman I am so sick of
Snyder fans that aren't fans that are cultists
that have manipulated his vision into their vision
of being angry trolling and beings and threatening
and and harming mentally emotionally and sometimes
physically others because they misinterpret a
character that was written before their parents
were born in most cases to not be this version
so while I love the Snyder films I think they
have harmed the pop culture Zeitgeist and that has
harmed the world we look to Art to be a commentary
on our time if we keep making our commentary in
our time so shitty so angry so vitrolic we're
because we'll keep living that way when the world
is Jaded and the world needs Superman that's when
Superman is there is the purpose of Superman to
be the antithesis to our jadedness to our Gloom
to our struggle in fact the reason I think the
authorities coming in is it's kind of that story
I think the authority is a very Snyder's take on
Batman and Superman version but it's intentionally
a commentary I honestly think it is a genius
move of James Gunn to bring in the authority
because he's the Snyder take on this universe it's
going to appease them but it's going to be a very
alarming moment when a certain amount of twists
happen and when people realize that homelander is
Donald Trump it's going to be a moment and people
are going to be very upset but I honestly think
the authority is the same commentary on this
vengeful superhero World in 1999 as the Snyder
world is today and I think it's an important
story to tell and honestly I think that's what the
authority is going to be and I think it's going
to be very interesting when Amanda Waller ends up
dealing with the authority and The Suicide Squad
and the authority are different commentaries on
cautionary tales about people with powers and all
of that ties into the darkness of the world we've
been living with DC and that's why it needs to be
brighter that's why we need the Green Lantern and
Brightest Day and darkest night we've been living
in a [__] dark night I think Zack Snyder just
didn't like weebs we barely saw any Clark Clark
was not in those movies and when he was the lowest
Lane relationship was really stiff and sterile and
this is Amy Adams and Henry Cavill two of the most
talented actors is not like they can't do that
job but they didn't make Clark a person because
he never got to be just a a Shucks kind of guy
and that's that's Clark because he is so innocent
and Earnest we never saw that and I think the
politeness of Clark Kent along with his earnesty
is also a thing that drives a lot of people that
are going through a tempestuous time and saying
there's a beautiful openness and welcomingness and
and just all wide-eyed Ness of Clark we don't get
to have if that Superman is vengeful the reason it
was so impactful when Clark Kent and Superman got
killed was because he was this unattainable thing
and to kill Superman so early into his run and to
make him so dark kind of eliminates the point and
on top of that they kill Jimmy Olsen Jimmy Olsen
is the humanity that is one of the things that
Superman looks to is like man I love these people
so much and Jimmy represents that they killed that
which in turn kills humanity and earnesty and hope
it's a very literal metaphor just as the the Perry
white metaphor when Perry white is is talking to
to Clark in the in the Daily Planet I think he
says something like oh we can't run this story
it's not 1938. that's Zack Snyder saying we can't
make a Superman that they did in 1938 that's the
character and I will be the first one to say that
archetypal characters are important because of the
lens you see them through that they're a mirror
for you but just like Spider-Man wouldn't work
if he didn't have responsibility Superman doesn't
work if he doesn't have hope so we need a Superman
that reflects the world we want to be for the sake
of the world again I don't think we've ever been
darker between the Internet connecting us in
ways that we weren't ready for between people
having this false sense of entitlement with fandom
with their own lives with perspectives on politics
with politics themselves the tribalism all the
things we've reached all of that is just a one
one hundredth of why we need Superman and at the
end of the day I do think that's why Henry Cavill
wasn't able to come back I don't think it was age
as much as as that was the thing that was publicly
stated I think that that was a factor obviously
uh they want to do you know a journey with Lois
and and you know Jimmy and all those things and
I understand that they said they're keeping uh
Aquaman and Flash for now I don't know how true
that is I wouldn't say hey these four movies that
are coming out aren't essential they're obviously
going to need to keep appearances that I'm not
saying it is true it isn't true I don't know I'm
not a DC but I am saying that the the reason Henry
Cavill the best Superman of my lifetime I love
Henry Cavill the reason Henry Cavill might not
have been able to keep going with Superman even
if it wasn't for the age thing is the association
with this when you look at Henry Cavill you
don't see the Superman that they wrote in 1938
you don't see the Superman that's in All-Star
Superman they're adapting you don't see the
Superman from For All Seasons or the one that is
beautifully saving that girl in all black because
she might kill herself one of the prettiest and
most impactful and sad Bittersweet pretty comic
pages of all time because he's also in Black I
know he's not all the time it's just the image
I have in my head if you have a character that's
that's close to killing themselves and another
character that's angry and vengeful it's not
The Duality it's not the dichotomy it's not
the thing that Superman is those pages don't work
unfortunately with Henry Cavill and I would have
loved to have seen him come back and get to play
the Superman he wanted he knew what Superman was
he talked about wanting to play that Superman he
got to for 30 seconds Black Adam but I do think
there was a lot of stuff tied to it and I do think
that rebooting the Snyder cut is is not an option
I think that restarting the DC Universe is the
move and that's just Superman Batman wise we get a
Batman that shot people and I I get that Batman in
the comics has used guns yeah Spider-Man's uh you
know accidentally killed people and the X-Men have
a vengeful eras to where they like wanted to take
out Humanity but that makes them the Brotherhood
of evil mutants if you adapt the X-Men and they
want to kill Humanity that's not the X-Men it's
the brother who moves just because in the comic
books doesn't mean it's accurate different
writers have different takes again archetypal
character but you've got to look at the the sum
of all the parts and Batman is a character who's
in his own way superstitious who has rules
if Batman doesn't have rules he's the joke
that's the point of the Joker the reason Batman
and Joker exists is to show the difference in
those characters if Batman has no rules and will
use a gun how is he different than the two-faced
side of Harvey Dent the reason Harvey Dent is so
interesting is because he represents the order
of Batman as well as the chaos of the Joker and
Batman seeing himself in that the White Knight
of the Dark Knight is Harvey Dent you need
Batman to have rules and his parents being
killed by a gun is why he literally and there's
there's very iconic frames where he snaps a gun
in half and says this is the weapon of cowards so
the fact that we had a Batman that used guns on
his car the fact that we had a Batman that that
frankly murdered defeats the purpose of Batman
Batman should be a cautionary tale yes he should
be someone very close to the edge he should be
someone psychologically abused and broken he
should be someone that is taking out his pain
on the mentally ill Batman is not something to
necessarily aspire to be he's cool yeah Batman's
cool but you need to also be like that's not good
that's why Pat and Batman is so great he would
not want to be Robert Pattinson losing his mind
just punching that person until he's broken the
reason that the Batman patents and worked so
well is that the symbol of hope he represents
the end him realizing that I am Vengeance can be
co-opted by the weak that I am vengeance is not
the answer the reason he needs to be a Spirit
of Hope much like Superman in fact the Arc of
Robert Pattinson's Batman is the arc we as a
society need to take with Superman vengeance
is a cautionary tale if you live angry and
you live vengeful you're not living we had a
vengeful violent Batman that that only got worse
and more violent we had the Thomas Wayne Batman
from an else world we had this character that
did not work in a world where we need hope and
again like I said with Superman we need hope now
more than ever so we need to look at a new Batman
which is going to be Batman with his family when
we look at this Batman as father of Damian Wayne
the darkness of Damian Wayne makes Bruce Wayne
lighter I think there's a very specific reason
they're bringing in Damian Wayne Damien Wayne is
not as beloved a character as Dick Grayson he's
not as beloved as Tim but he is a character that
changes Bruce and I think it's going to be very
interesting adding a maternal element I think that
Batman has always had a paternal element with his
Wards and with his robins and those certain things
that give you that beautiful dichotomy between his
upbringing when he was raised he didn't have a
family so all he wanted was a family if you look
at the dichotomy between the Joker who is is the
thing he he can't be because of chaos or like I
said Harvey dents or how Mr Freeze is his opposite
because his love for Nora mirrors Bruce's love for
Gotham or the guilt of Nora mirroring his guilt
of his family all of Batman's best Rogues are
mirrors of Batman that's why he's a psychological
character that's why he works in so many different
ways the reason all these characters sing Catwoman
being a thief and Batman loving her is him feeling
the guilt of that the reason all this works is
Batman is all of us but we should aspire to be
Superman and I love the idea of Batman being all
of us and going I never had a family I have a son
of Batman going like look at this little [__]
he's killing people and harming others I gotta
fix that but he's my son so I can't do what
I usually do with criminals that's going to
be a great story and because of when it takes
place in his life him being older that allows
for Dick Grayson to argue Nightwing that allows
for potential Red Hood greatness that allows for
all of these stories deeper into the Mythos and
because we haven't had a Batman with a family yet
this is a great way to separate Robert Pattinson's
you can have your darking Brewing Batman that I
love the David Fincher Batman while also having a
fun a little bit lighter perhaps even as light as
like you know bat shark repellent probably not
but you you could have a lighter Batman in the
family Batman and that's because of Damien Wayne
I'm not saying he's slapstick I'm not saying it's
going to be brightly colored tights it might be
Neil Adams blue that'd be cool I'd like to see
you around this blue but I do think Damian Wayne
establishes a tone I think that was a very smart
announcement I think putting Batman older than
Superman allows for a very interesting story of
Batman being a more seasoned veteran while maybe
Superman's on year three he's not it's not her
origin every keeps saying the Superman origin
but I do think having Superman younger than
Batman allows for a different kind of conversation
about Batman's fear and apprehension at first of
Superman and how a lighter Superman is gonna be
much better suited to the broad Justice League
Strokes a lighter Superman is much better suited
to encounter a Green Lantern if the Green Lantern
landed in Gotham that penguin Colin Farrell's
running around in that would ruin the entire
world that that world they built would be done
so I think this Batman is the best possible thing
to fit in the Justice League and expand that
shared Universe out I think this Superman is
the best possible thing for our shared Universe
because we need to believe in things again so
if this video pissed you off I'm sorry and I don't
want you to take that out on me or anyone else I
think Superman will be something that hopefully
you can find to not see as cheesy for being bright
that you cannot see as wow he's just got all these
Powers that's boring because the point is Hope and
aspiration and to believe in something greater
than ourselves he's supposed to be better than
us we're supposed to want to be him and he's
supposed to want to be us Superman should not
reflect our world our world should try to reflect
Superman Batman should not be something we want
to be we should want to help Batman I really
really think these new takes are going to be
fantastic and I really really hope that if you've
been dealing with some of the more Angry DC fans
it hasn't changed your love for DC Comics I love
DC Comics I love these characters I talk about
Marvel a lot because I've never felt comfortable
dealing with some of the more negative DC fans and
they've only gotten bigger more empowered and and
stronger in their mind it's not started with me
not having as much to say because there weren't
as many adaptations of DC that the adaptations
came out and just I got driven out of town and
I'm not going to do that anymore I'm not going
to be weak I'm not going to be a subservient
to trolls I'm not going to let the enemy win
so don't make yourself an enemy of comic books
don't make yourself an enemy of DC change is
important and these characters are important to
a lot of people stop being a dick all right much
love you lovelies citizens of reject Nation uh if
you like this type of video let me know [Music]